[Music]
guys I'm so excited to be here I wore my
best Karndean for you you're welcome
I was a little bit late getting here
though cuz I was teaching a yoga class
that ladies like that did not happen
here I had to not teach a yoga class I
went to one obviously it was pretty
awesome though because the yoga teacher
she let me do the modified version of
everything so like the class would do
downward dog and she won't let me eat
raviolis they do a child's pose let me
take a nap in the corner I love yoga
namaste I am a big fan of the restaurant
Hooters obviously because why would you
not be it's a pretty great place
the waitresses there are pretty awesome
because they get they get a little
skeptical about people who come in there
and asked to buy one of their outfits
and they get especially suspicious when
that person is me I went into a hooters
and I went up to the waitress and I was
like hey I'd like to buy on your shirt
so she's like um what size the small
she's like when they run kind of small
much even better let's do this it's my
goal in life to buy the entire hooters
outfit and just go into the hooters and
start waiting on tables you know I just
like put them on my guts hanging out
he's like for Doozers sitting there
watching football and I come in there
they're like what
no I didn't order that
hey you don't want some chicken wings on
it real for a second guys have you ever
been compared to the entire honey boo
boo family Wow just me Coco cool oh my
god that show came out and everybody
starts weeping oh my god you look just
like honey boo boo you got impersonate
honey boo boo like that was not a
compliment thank you well it's even
worse is when I realized that all I had
to do in order to impersonate honey Boo
Boo's mom this is all I had to do I'm
not proud I know it's hard to tell by
the way I'm dressed right now but I am a
lesbian what that's crazy you're so
feminine I know there's anybody here in
the closet anybody
we'll talk about that later I'm not
judging I was a bit of a late bloomer I
didn't come out 1225 and I remember when
I was in college my mom would be like I
don't understand why I get so upset when
your friend Michelle goes out on dates
with guys and I was like but god she's
my best friend you don't get it
apparently I did not get it I had no
idea dressed just like this too when I
finally decided to come out it's really
scary especially telling your dad cuz
like your dad your dad you know he's the
one who teaches you how to play softball
which is like the gayest sport there is
in fact some people call it gateway
sport it's true softball then lesbian
there's some straight girls here right
now who are like oh my god
[Music]
I would solve on high school I was third
base and I was really good what does
this mean
major K we're coming for you grab the
Subaru let's go put on your Tevas is
gonna be a long journey so I told my dad
I took it into this hometown festival in
the south to tell him you know safety in
numbers and and we're sitting there and
I'm like so nervous I can barely talking
my denim jean genet this point is really
nervous cause he thinks I'm special it's
all right dad I'm gay and he [ __ ] his
head back he's like oh [ __ ] and then
he's like well well well you will want
to go to Old Navy and get your new
outfit like dad what does own Navy have
to do with me being a lesbian he's like
I don't know there's no best [ __ ] that's
my time you guys thank you so much